pour la deuxième année consécutive les
six millions de musulmans de france
s'apprête à vivre des célébrations du
ramadan entravée par les restrictions
sanitaires
cette année les lieux de culte ne seront
pas fermées mais le couvre-feu de 19
heures prises les musulmans des prières
du soir à la mosquée et des
retrouvailles conviviales de la rupture
du jeûne
comme l'expliquent ses fidèles bas cette
année comme lé mesures sanitaires on
peut inviter personnes par précaution
donc moi cette année je le fais à la
maison ni vu ni connu voilà c'est triste
mais c'est comme ça cette année la
différence elle est énorme
c'est un mois de piété ou les gens
fréquentent les mosquées beaucoup plus
que les autres jours et cause de ces
mesures de qu'ovide nous sommes privés
de certains prirent importante pendant
notre culte il ya deux prières sur cinq
cette année les prières et la rupture du
jeûne eux peuvent se suivre sur des
réseaux sociaux ou encore sur zoom y les
mosquées adopte un protocole sanitaires
strictes
c'est le cas de celle de drancy en
banlieue parisienne paulhe elle croit ça
veut dire interdire de prix et si c'est
la seule derrien infidèle ici une
deuxième fidèles et les gens et à
presque 2 mètres entre eux
deuxièmement on n'utilise pas le tapis
un moment très directement sur tapis et
maintenant on oblige chaque fidèle
hermès en tapis ça fait qu'ils aient
plus de contacts même les abolitions
levitte sauf en cas d'urgence les
fidèles explique se plier aux consignes
redoutant les effets de l'épidémie mais
n'avait qu'une ou les tapis de la prière
au drame lundi que nous l'aimons
obligatoire fait les jeunes à l'entrée
la sortie voilà la santé avant tout bien
géré crie même l'imam et les il doit
tout autant rappeler que doit mettre
chacun ramène ça tapait fos avait
d'abord et pour mettre la distance
chacun à sa place à m
franchement avec cette mosquée là on est
bien respectée séparément et d'autres
mots ce qu'il en train de suivre ces
malgré sa peine de voir le ramadan
confiné l'imam de drancy hassen
chalghoumi insiste sur la nécessité de
se préserver du virus est quand même il
ya de la tristesse ce que les mamans des
fêtes pour comme toutes les religions
sont des moments de partage
c'est des moments de partage leur joie
ils partagent leur fait et partagent
leurs expériences maintenant c'est
difficile même entre nous il faut avoir
toujours de cette distance on essaie de
donner cet esprit à nos fidèles que la
vie humaine il plus sacré que n'importe
quel texte dogme prioritaires votre vive
la halle la sécurité de la vie de la
personne de sa famille de ses proches
les stars ça veut dire la rupture du
jeûne le soir c'est une famille stricte
la prière la nuit a pas des prières
clandestine c'est interdit on peut pas
faire une chose à l'interdiction au nom
du d'une religion on en devoirs des
récompenses du dieu élément important de
ce ramadan la vaccination a été déclaré
illicite par certaines instances du
culte musulman comme par la commission d
imam de la grande mosquée de paris
un pas supplémentaire vers un retour à
la normale pour le ramadan de 2022